make of thyselves  that which he desire  be it a lord  be it a god  but should he fail to become ought at  all  he will be forsaken  amounting only to sacrifices  [Music]  thy kind are all other peace  emboldened by the flames  champions  welcome  a celebration of war  again festival  [Music]  i pray  that the guidance of grace abandons you  why accept the burden of their grace  or be fooled by the dogmatic ramblings  of the fingers  rise with us  against the earth tree  never met someone with a taste for brown  or contrast we've made good mates  [Music]  the  foreign  and once all is done  we shall see each other  once more  now  go forth  become  elder lord  you